Good morning John, and thanks for making our
most disliked Vlogbrothers video ever!
Apparently, all you have to do is insult a
fictional vigilante.
To be fair, though, to everyone in the comments,
you pretty much got Batman entirely wrong.
Bruce Wayne does contribute to the infrastructure
of that fictional, blighted city as much as
he can, given its deep rooted culture of corruption
that makes it so that there is literally no
one else in the city who can help.
Except for old guy sidekicks number one and
number two and that woman who isn't Katie
Holmes and Jean-Baptiste Emmanuel Zorg.
Of course I know that your video on Tuesday
wasn't really about Batman.
It was just using Batman as a tool to say
something: that individual people cannot have,
and do not have, and should not have the power
to change everything on their own, and when
they try to do it, it always turns out bad.
So, maybe it's odd that we spend so much time
celebrating that idea in our media.
But, I don't actually think it's odd; I think
it's complicated.
Batman's values and actions are a reflection
of our own values and actions, or our desires
to act, to make the world better... in the
ways that we want it to be better.
Of course, then wrapped up in an entertaining
package with great plot and epic explosions
and stuff.
We all do know that there is evil in the world,
so Gotham's underbelly simplifies and represents
that for us.
Gotham's criminals aren't a product of disenfranchisement
and undervaluation by culture.
"Some people", as Alfred tells Master Wayne,
"just want to watch the world burn."
So, Batman is a reflection of our anger and
our ambition and our frustration that our
powerlessness to fix the things that we see
is wrong with the world.
I think this is fine.
Gotham's evil incarnate is a simplification
of the problems that we face, and Batman is
a simplification of us, of all of us, who
do the good that makes the world work.
So then, in some peculiar way, we are all
bat-people: not the heroes Earth needs, but
the heroes Earth just happened to get.
We build roads and teach children and clean
sewers and invent new kinds of lightbulbs
and care for each other and better ourselves.
It's a simple vigilantism: the vigilantism
of everyday kindness and hard work.
Of course, Batman is a more complex simplification
than, say, Superman, who is so simple that
he's really not even relatable.
We see ourselves in the cracks in his façade,
in his anger and frustration and sadness,
because we have all those things, too.
And for this reflection to work, to sell the
most movie tickets -we're talking about the
movies here, not the comics- Batman has to
be as broadly representative as possible,
so his values are just kind of an average
amalgam of the values of our culture.
And his major characteristics of being hot
and buff and rich and white and male are either
things that we see as unquestionably advantageous
in things that we ourselves would like to
be, or, as like, the default state, which
is I think where we start running into trouble.
My biggest problem with Batman, and to be
fair, all of the mass-cultural movie things
that we spend billions of dollars creating
and marketing, is that in an attempt to represent
most broadly, they continue to under-represent
the same groups over and over and over and
over again!
In attempting to reflect our culture and its
weird emphasis on maleness and whiteness as
the default, they don't just submit to that
culture, they help reinforce it, they help
create it, somehow leaving the majority of
people under-represented in a simplification
that had representation as its initial goal,
which is pretty messed up.
So yeah, it's complicated.
All simplicity is a lie!
And we could do a better job.
And in comics, they do a better job.
Because the comics don't cost 500 million
dollars to make and thus can take some risks,
which is why that's where all the interesting
stuff happens.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
It's October 10th, which means that it's time
to start thinking about the Project for Awesome,
people.
We're working on some very cool perks.
One of the things is a compilation album of
nerdfighter music; anything inspired by anything
to do with nerdfighteria.
If you wold like to contribute to that compilation
album, there is some information in the description.
What's happening over on Games with Hank?
UH-OH I'M SORRY DOLPHIN MOM!
That is a jellyfish!
Ohh, woahh, look at me goo!
Everyone's a winner... until their legs break
in half.
No...
NoOO- AAA-HAAAAAA!
Yeah, it-- it's fun.
You should come visit.